has gone breast support apply hair we're
playing honey pop don't tell Knights yet
oh [__] it's morning
oh you can't [__] in the morning alright
let's just talk to her curious all right
what is it
how important is family to you 100%
[Music]
okay so we talked to this girl a lot so
we need to buy some food for her era
have a hamburger and some doughnuts
let's go to our other waifu but she
doesn't need to know about our other
waifu am i right ladies
[Music]
okay alright
Tiffany I love academic environment
all right let's okay so now we go to
Jesse whatever [__] off we're gonna have
to be okay when you asked about my
education what did I say to you it's sad
that I remember this but she she dropped
out of high school I know more about
Jesse that I know about marts how often
do you masturbate when you're in a
relationship
I obviously want to do that I have
self-control I have a hard time
believing that one what are you talking
about 100% 100% I agree with you let's
go on a date you know what let's just go
on a date right now you and me girl
all right here we go Oh Oh whoo Oh if we
play our cards right she will go home to
us this is the most exciting gameplay of
2012 why am i hitting the table no one
knows do i what
[Music]
keep it cold rice
all right let's do this
I think you have to be as fascist okay
it's all about being fast I'm half Sonic
so I would know I know a thing or two
about finishing fast you know what I
mean all right well that's nice too bad
you can't see those anime titties oh
[Music]
this place is about to blow
Oh stuffed bear stuffed bear do
something damn it I keep going oh god oh
god oh god oh my god it's happening
Wow I wish I was a bad
[Music]
lost my animu virginity right there
what's up Oh
this game was real life I'd be a goddamn
player look at me look how [__] cool
I am right now you see me now haters you
see me now feels dirty only was this
good in real life them titties yes I
[Music]
think I think I need to quit this game
and reevaluate my life I should probably
not have film myself playing this I
underestimated you last night I usually
have to fake it it's not the first time
I heard that Brice I'm gonna end accept
so here do you love cranny crash do you
love any more girls
of course you do of car everyone that's
an emu